la guerre en ukraine et les craintes
d'approvisionnement exerce une pression
à la hausse sur l'aluminium la russie
est le troisième producteur mondial
d'aluminium en importance après l'inde
et la chine le canada arrive au 4e rang
avec nous ce soir jean simard le
président et chef de direction de
l'association de l'aluminium du canada
bonsoir bonsoir alors la guerre en
ukraine fait grimper les prix de
l'aluminium à des niveaux record
pourquoi
premièrement il faut comme vous l'avez
mentionné la russie est un des grands
producteurs mondiaux d'aluminium et si
le plus grand exportateur aussi
d'aluminium relativement à sa production
donc le plus grand pourcentage de sa
production qui est parmi les plus grands
au monde est exportée sur les marchés
mondiaux c'est donc dire que à partir du
moment où ce métal la rencontre des
barrières à l'entrée il va y avoir une
tension qui s'exerce entre l'offre et la
demande mondiale qui va prendre un
certain temps à combler donc à enlever
un peu de cette tension avec du métal
qui pourrait venir du moyen orient ou
ailleurs dans le monde pour répondre à
un marché par exemple en amérique du
nord est ce que il ya déjà une réduction
des exportations russes sur le marché
mondial présentement compte tenu de
toutes les sanctions sont en place on
voit que quand on regarde la courbe des
prix depuis le mois de novembre environ
novembre décembre on a vu le marché
réagir aux annonces de poutine ou
contrat danse aux contre-propositions de
baden et le marché a donc commencé s
compter les problèmes qui s'en venait et
c'est depuis ce temps le convoi nos os
là on voit on voit clairement quand même
une hausse marquée au cours des derniers
mois la wii du prix de l'aluminium en a
sorti graphique sur dix ans il ya eu des
démos maintenir augmentait mais jamais
comme maintenant oui mais ce qu'on voit
sur votre tableau qui est très
intéressant c'est que tout ça a commencé
à peu près vers 2014 avec
l'occupation de la crimée où est-ce que
déjà des sanctions avait été prise
contre le métal russe par la suite dont
je pense qu'on est on s'en bat vers 2018
et c'est des sanctions qui ont été
prises contre les oligarques dont oleg
deripaska le propriétaire de rusal qui a
été sanctionnée à l'époque et à ce
moment là le marché américain où est ce
que les russes avaient avant 2014 à peu
près 25% du marché d'importation après
7% et pas assez à 5% est donc
aujourd'hui on peut présumer que on va
se rapprocher de zéro éventuellement
parce que c'est difficile de comprendre
comment quelqu'un
entreprendre une relation contractuelle
pour acheter du métal russes aux états
unis ou en amérique du nord il traîne
produit de l'aluminé wii qui sert à la
fabrication de l'aluminium de la russie
oui la ssii s'est complètement arrêté la
raffinerie nicolas rey qui est utilisé
par rusal pourrait provisionner ses
usines est fermé depuis maintenant
environ une semaine et on comprend on a
besoin de deux tonnes d'aluminé pour
produire une tonne d'aluminium alors
c'est un étreint extrêmement important
pour assurer une production continue et
donc la russie va devoir
s'approvisionner ailleurs possiblement
ils ont une autre infini qui est très
importante en irlande à gué niche
mais ils vont ça ne suffirait pas à
répondre à leurs besoins ils vont devoir
se retourne et qui sait vers la chine ou
d'autres sources d'approvisionnement
potentiel et le monde devra se trouver
de l'aluminium ailleurs au québec est-ce
que les alumineries québécoises peuvent
profiter en guillemets de ce qui se
passe présentement elles vont en
profiter non ports quant à l'ajout de de
production parce qu'on produit déjà à
près de 95 % de la capacité de nos
usines c'est vraiment le maximum
opérationnel mais elles vont en profiter
du fait que le cri va être vos demeurer
très haut on est vraiment un pli
historique aujourd'hui si on combine
le prix mondial elle m e 3 mois ou à la
prime régionale donc
3670 dollar environ à la prime régionale
qui est à 850 qui du jamais vue
historique on est donc rendu à 4600 $ us
la tonne transiger ici en amérique du
nord et c'est pas demain matin que ça va
diminuer et ça ça veut dire quoi dans
toute la chaîne de valeur que d'avoir un
prix de l'aluminium aussi élevé le
danger si ça dure aussi la menace de
substitution vers d'autres matériaux
dépendant des secteurs d'utilisation
pensons par exemple à l'aérospatiale ou
l'aluminium se colle taille avec le
matériau composite par exemple alors on
pourrait penser qu'un navigateur
pour réduire ses coûts
d'approvisionnement pour fabriquer des
avions qui vont être utilisés pendant 20
ans 30 ans décide de changer de source
de matériaux mais même ça c'est très
complexe parce qu'il faut re certifier
ses composants clair il faut que
certifiés le fournisseur puis en bout de
ligne dû composer site du pétrole
aussi ça coûte cher un dernier mot
monsieur simard sur les cyber attaques
pourquoi il ya des super attaques qui
visent des alumineries
c'est un grand complexe industriel une
aluminerie et c'est un contexte
industriel qui de plus en plus et tout
automatiser utilise de l'intelligence
artificielle
puis quelque part c'est un actif
stratégique dans une économie nous 9
alumineries sont considérées par le
gouvernement canadien comme autant
d'actifs stratégiques d'intérêt national
alors il est certain que quand on
regarde par exemple des tables ou en
temps réel sur l'internet qui nous
mentent les attaques à travers le bon
c'est à la seconde c'est quand fillon
peut l'y suivent alors c'est sûr que les
alumineries les aciéries toutes ces
grands complexes industriels font partie
des cibles vie et par ces prédateurs il
faudrait que le gouvernement passe à
l'action au canada et
se donne un plan de protection des
actifs stratégiques les ponts des voies
ferroviaires et les grandes industries d
alumine merci beaucoup d'espoir merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]